CHRIS LATIMER: Hi, and
welcome to our session today.
My name is Chris Latimer.
I'm one of the product
managers here at Google Cloud.
And today I'm
going to be talking
about building and managing
APIs for serverless
with Google Cloud.
There are going
to be five things
we're going to look at today.
We're going to
start off by looking
at how we can build services.
We're going to use the Cloud
Code plug in that GCP provides
the developers to
make it easy to get
started with GCP development.
We're going to look
at how we can deploy
those services to Cloud Run.
And then we're
going to look at how
we can combine multiple
services together
to form an API using GCP's
brand-new API gateway, which
is just announced in beta.
Once we have that
API created, we're
going to see how we
can secure that API.
And then finally, once
everything's up and running,
we're going to
take a look at how
we can monitor that API
using Cloud Logging and Cloud
Monitoring so that, if
anything's not working the way
we expect, we can get
alerted to that fact.
For our first step,
we're going to look
at how we can build services.
We're going to use the
Cloud Code plugin that
comes with IntelliJ.
Now, you could also
use visual code
if that's your preferred IDE.
Now, there are a few
steps that I've already
taken ahead of time.
So I've already
installed IntelliJ.
I've already installed
the Cloud Code plugin.
I also have installed
Docker and the gcloud CLI.
So if you're going
to follow along,
you may want to do the same
steps on your workstation.
So let's jump to the
demo and take a look
at how we can build a service
using the Cloud Code plugin
and then get that
deployed to Cloud Run.
To get started in
IntelliJ, we're
going to select
create a new project.
And we are going to select the
Cloud Run option that comes
with the Cloud Code plugin.
And I'm going to pick
the Java version.
We'll give this a name.
We'll call it customers
API and click Finish.
Once this is done,
IntelliJ is going
to look at the
project structure.
It's going to detect that
we have a Maven POM file.
We can add that POM file and
switch this over to a Maven
project now inside of IntelliJ.
That's going to give us all
the standard Maven features
that we'd want.
If we take a look
over at the code base,
we'll see that, within
the file system,
the Cloud Code plugin has
given us a good starting point.
It gives us a
Spring Boot app that
will run right out of the box.
So if I configure my
SDK and tell IntelliJ
I want to use Java
11, I can then
click over here on
this spring-boot
and select the
spring-boot run option.
This is going to start
my application locally.
And so after a few seconds,
this is going to come up.
And it's going to
start successfully.
And we can verify
that by looking over
here at the log messages that
are printed to the console.
We see that it successfully
started, now listening
and accepting traffic.
If I come into my browser
now and I hit localhost 8080,
we can see that this
app is in fact running.
So right out of the box, we can
get a web application working.
But what we really want is we
want a microservice that we
can deploy to Cloud Run.
And so rather than walking
through the individual steps
of how to create an API inside
of Spring Boot which is well
documented elsewhere
on the internet,
I have already pre-configured
this in my git repository.
So I'm going to start
off by checking out
a tag here called basic API.
And then once I do this, we
can go back into the IDE.
And here, if we look
at the file system,
we're going to see now that,
instead of the web app,
we have a controller, an
entity, and a service.
Inside the controller--
you can see
this is a REST controller-- it
has a single mapping to slash.
And the way that we are going to
process these incoming requests
is we're going to use a service
called customer service.
Looking inside here, this
is just a mock service.
I don't have a
database behind here.
But it is going to populate
a list of entities,
a list of entities
called customer,
that has a number of different
fields associated with it.
We can now run this the
same way that we did before.
So we'll use the Spring Boot
plugin, use the run target.
Again, we're going to see
messages printed out here
to the console.
And after a few
seconds, we're going
to see one that says that our
app is started successfully.
And if we look, scroll
over here to the right,
we do see that same message.
So once that's started,
we can come now
over into the terminal window.
And let's issue a cURL
command on localhost 8080.
We can pretty print this JSON
with the Python JSON tool.
And there we go.
Our API is successfully
now running locally
here on my workstation.
Now we're ready to deploy our
microservice into Cloud Run.
So let's click on Edit
Configurations up here.
This is going to bring up a
form that comes with Cloud Code.
We can pick our GCP project.
We can pick our
region that we want
to deploy our service into.
We can select a
service name and then
whether we want to have
authentication or not.
In this case, we do.
So we'll select that.
Last thing we need to
specify is where we should
upload this container image.
In this case, we're going to use
the Google Container Registry.
So we'll give it a name
here of customers API
and note that my project
is also specified here.
Also important to note that I've
already pre-enabled the Google
Container Registry on my project
before I started this demo.
So you may get an error
if you try to upload this
and you haven't enabled that
service on your project.
Now let's go ahead and save
our configuration here.
And now let's run it.
So as this runs,
it's essentially
going to do all
the steps that we
need to actually
get our container up
and running on Cloud Run.
So it's going to build
a container locally.
It's going to interact with GCR.
It's going to create the
necessary tags that it needs.
If it finds the
container in the cache,
it's not going to rebuild it.
And then it's ultimately going
to deploy this to Cloud Run.
And after a few seconds
here, what we should see
is that it'll come back
and say it's deployed
and now accepting traffic.
And traffic is going to
be accessible via this URL
that you see right here.
Now, remember we
secured this API.
And so if we come back
to the terminal window
and we try to cURL
that URL, we're
going to get a message saying
that your client does not
have permissions, essentially,
to make this call.
And that was back here
on this configuration
where we said require
authentication.
If we had said allow
unauthenticated connections,
then we would have
been able to access
this API just fine as is.
But we really want the
gateway to be that entry point
into our API.
So we want to say--
we want to tell Cloud Run to
authenticate these requests so
that all of our clients have
to come through the gateway.
And the only
authenticated client
that's going to be able
to call into our Cloud Run
back indirectly is
going to be the gateway.
So we see that the
API has been deployed.
We can hit it here
locally using cURL.
But let's jump over
to Cloud Console
and just verify that
everything looks fine there.
We'll navigate
down to Cloud Run.
And just as expected, we see
the customer API deployed,
green checkbox next to it.
Everything is looking good here.
So let's jump back into the
presentation and recap what
we've seen so far.
All right, so coming
back from the demo,
let's take a look
at what we just saw.
The first thing we saw
is how to get started
using the Cloud Code plugin.
This set up a nice
workspace for us.
It set our file system up so
that we had all of the pieces
that we needed to start
building our actual service
that we're interested in.
We took that initial
starting point.
And we used it to
create a nice RESTful
service using Spring Boot.
And then once we were satisfied
that that was running locally
the way that we wanted,
we configured the IDE
to deploy that into Cloud Run.
Once that was there, we
saw that the deployment
worked successfully.
And now we have our service
up and running exactly
as we hoped it would.
And so currently, this is what
our cloud instance looks like.
We have a single customer API
that's running in Cloud Run.
And if we wanted to, we could
have a client make calls
directly to this service.
If all we had was a single
service and a single client,
this is not such a bad option.
We could create a
service account.
We could give that service
account to the client.
They could make calls.
And everything would
work pretty good.
The problem that's
going to happen
is that, as we start adding
more and more services,
we're putting more of
a burden on our client.
They're going to
have to remember
which service is responsible for
which piece of functionality.
They're going to have to route
to the right place each time.
And that can be inconvenient.
It can also be inconvenient
for us as the API providers,
because now we have to think
about who we're going to break
whenever we make a change.
What would be better is if
we could put a single API
facade in front
of these services
so that, for our
clients, we can give them
one consistent interface
that they can use.
And we can insulate
ourselves from those clients.
We have flexibility to scale,
and deploy, and make changes
to our backend services without
worrying that our clients are
going to need to change.
So let's jump into our
next demo and take a look
at how we can use services that
are deployed onto Cloud Run,
put an API gateway
in front of those
to create one consistent
API facade for our clients.
So let's jump back
into the cloud console
here and navigate to Cloud Run.
Like we showed on
the presentation,
we want to be able to
have an API gateway that's
going to sit in front
of multiple services
so that our API
clients don't have
to worry about which service
to route which requests to.
We just want them to
have one, nice API facade
that they can call into.
And we want API gateway to
handle both the security
on that API as
well as the routing
so that we send those
requests to the right service
on the backend.
To configure API
gateway, we need
to have an open API
specification file.
And it needs to have all of
the resources in our API.
So in this case,
you can see that we
have a customers resource,
an accounts resource,
and an orders resource.
Once we have that setup,
we need to configure
the value for host.
Now, this may be a
little bit surprising
if you're used to
using open API.
The value that we're going
to put here in the host field
is going to be a combination
of the identifier
that we want to use for the
API here in this field called
API ID as well as our project.
And this is going to conform
to the standard service naming
structure that's
used within Google.
So for right now, just
think about this as,
this is just the format
that you have to follow.
Don't think too much about why
this format is the way it is.
This is just the way that
API gateway gets configured.
And then here on
the title field,
we want to put in
that same API ID.
And we'll see in later
steps that we're going to--
that this value that
we put in for title
is going to show up when
we go to create an API key
and when we go to restrict
that key to only be
able to call certain services.
Once we have host
and title configured,
the next thing to do is to
add in routing instructions
for API gateway.
So for each of these
resources, we're
going to use the
x-google-backend
that you see here.
And we're going to
put in an address that
corresponds to the
correct service that's
running in Cloud Run.
So for example, for
the customers resource,
we want to write to
the customer service.
So how do we do that?
First thing that
we have to know is
the address for each of
our services on Cloud Run.
And so to find the address
that we want to route to,
we can navigate back
to Cloud console
and find the service
that we're interested in.
And if we click on
the service, it's
going to bring us to
a more detailed view.
And you can see
that, right up here,
we have the address where
the service is accessible.
And we can copy this
to our clipboard.
And then we will
jump back to the IDE
and back to our open
API specification.
And then here on
the address field,
we'll just simply paste this in.
So here is our address
for the customer service
that's currently
running on Cloud Run.
Next we'll do that exact same
thing for the account API.
We will grab its
URL from Cloud Run.
We'll come back to the IDE and
paste that value in the address
field here.
Then we'll go back to
the cloud console again,
this time grabbing
our orders API,
copy the location
for this service.
And just like before,
we'll paste that
into the address field here.
At this point, our open API
specification is ready to go.
And we can use this to create a
new API inside of API gateway.
To do that, we're going
to go to Cloud console.
We're going to navigate down
to the API gateway option.
And we're going to
click on Create API.
Here we're going to give
our API a display name.
We'll call it ecommerce.API.
And we need to use
the same API ID here
that we used in our
open API specification.
So we called it a
ecommerce there.
We need to make sure we call
it ecommerce here as well.
Now, this step takes a
little while to complete.
It's usually one to two minutes
or so for it to get done.
And then once it
does wrap up, we're
ready then to upload our open
API specification that we just
created.
So we'll click on Browse.
We'll find the file
in our file system.
And once we do, we'll
select that, open API file.
And then we'll give
our configuration here
a display name.
And this will just show up on
the list when we go to the UI.
And then we're going to
select the service account
that we want to use to
connect to that backend,
to the Cloud Run services
that we are routing to.
So again, this step
is going to take
you know around 30
seconds or so to complete.
And then once this
wraps up, we'll
be able to deploy our new
API config to an API gateway.
So just like before, we're
going to give our API
gateway a display name--
we'll call it the
commerce API gateway--
and pick a location.
We'll use US Central.
That's where all of our Cloud
Run services are deployed.
Click Create.
And there we go.
It's created.
I can now click on this API.
And if I do, I'll
see that I have
a gateway associated with it.
This is deployed.
And this gateway is
accepting traffic at the URL
that you see listed
under gateway URL here.
Now, I can take this URL.
I can go to my browser.
And I can just simply
issue a request.
And I'll call the gateway
URL slash customers.
And voila, there we go.
We get our data back
from our customers API.
So now let's jump
back into Slides.
And let's recap what
we saw in this demo.
All right, so what do
we see in that demo?
Well, we started off with
our open API specification.
And we started off by
defining all the resources
that our API is going to
expose to the clients.
And then we configured API
gateway with the parameters
that API gateway needs.
And that was really our API ID,
our title, in our project ID.
And then finally, we updated
each of those resources
to point to the correct
service on Cloud Run
so that when an
API call comes in,
it's going to be routed
to the right place.
Once we had our open API
spec all ready to go,
we went back into Pantheon.
And we configured API gateway.
Now, you saw that there were a
few steps that we went through.
And one of those steps is
we uploaded our open API
specification.
And we created an API config.
And in the demo, we
just created one.
And we took that one
API configuration.
And we deployed it directly
to the API gateway.
But APIs can actually have
multiple configurations
associated with them.
And this can be pretty useful
for a number of use cases.
If you're doing something
like API versioning
or you're building out
an SLDC, maybe you're
going to have a different
configuration in your test,
versus dev, versus
prod environment,
API configs can help you
to solve those use cases.
And right now,
after our demo, this
is what our
environment looks like.
We have three different services
that are running on Cloud Run.
We have an API gateway now
with an API called ecommerce
that's fronting those services.
And then our clients now
have a consistent interface
that they can call
into to access
any pieces of those services
that are running in Cloud Run.
Now, there is just one problem.
That API is wide
open to the internet.
So anyone at this point
can make a call to our API.
And it's going to
respond with data.
So what we'd like to do is we'd
like to put in place security
so that not just anybody can
call into our API, but only
clients that we authorize.
And so why don't we
jump back into the demo
and look at how we can use API
gateway to add API key security
to provide a more secure
API for our clients.
To configure API security,
we're going to come back
to our open API specification.
As you can see, I have a
new security definition
that I've already added.
It has a type of API key.
It has a name of key.
And it has an n value query.
So what this means is that I'm
going to look for an API key.
I'm going to look for a
query parameter called key.
And that's what I'm going
to interpret as the API key.
Now, I need to then go to
each individual resource.
And I need to add in
a security definition.
And I'm going to
just simply reference
that API key that I had in
the security definition above.
And what this is
going to do is it's
going to then require any
incoming API calls to either
provide a valid API key
that's been authorized
to use this resource.
Or else it's going
to reject the call.
Now that we've configured
security within our open API
specification, we can come
back here to the Cloud Console.
And we can find the same
ecommerce API and the same API
gateway that we created
in the previous demo.
And we need to create a
new API configuration.
So to do that, let's go to the
Config tab that you see here.
And we're going to
click on Upload Config.
Just like we did
in the last demo,
we're going to click on Browse.
We're going to find that open
API specification that we just
created with our security
definitions in it.
We're going to select
that file and upload it.
Now we'll give it a new
display name here as well.
We'll call this one
ecommerce secure config.
And then, just
like before, we're
going to select the
service account that we're
going to use to authenticate
the calls to Cloud Run.
We'll pick the same gateway.
We could have created a
new gateway here as well,
but we're going to just override
the config that was deployed
to that existing gateway.
And we will wait for
around 30 seconds
or so while our configuration
is uploaded and deployed
to that new gateway.
And after patiently waiting
for a few seconds here,
we will see that this step
will complete successfully.
As soon as this step wraps
up, our configuration
is live and is deployed
to our API gateway.
So just like we did
in the last demo,
we can come back over here
to our browser window.
And we can issue a request
to our gateway URL slash
customers.
But this time we're going
to get a different response.
Last time we got back data.
We got back customer data.
This time we're getting back
an error message saying,
hey, this API is expecting
you to provide an API key,
but you didn't provide one.
So now let's take
a look at what we
need to do to get
valid credential
so that we can call this API.
If you recall when we were very
first setting up our open API
specification, I said, we're
going to use this API ID.
And we're going to put that
ID into the title field.
So let me show you
exactly how that title
value is going to be
important to API consumers.
Before we can get a valid
key to call our API,
we need to enable this API
within our GCP project.
And the way we're going
to do that is we're
going to come here to the
APIs and Services dashboard,
click on Enable
APIs and Services.
And that title,
that ecommerce title
is what we're going
to search for.
And that's the API that we're
going to find right here.
And once this pops up,
we can click on Enable.
It's going to take
a few seconds.
It's going to say this
is not a Google API
and give you a
little warning there.
But after a few seconds,
it's going to then
be enabled on our project.
And once it is, we
can then navigate over
to the APIs and Services
Credential section.
And we can create
a new credential.
In this case, it's
going to be an API key.
That key is created.
And then we're going to
want to restrict that key.
Otherwise, it's going to
give us access to everything.
Once we click on
restrict key, we're
going to see a list of
services we can select from.
Now, because we enabled
the ecommerce API,
we're going to see
ecommerce in that list.
And now this key
that we're generating
is only going to be
good for making calls
to our ecommerce API.
Now we can click here.
And we can copy our
key to a clipboard.
And then we'll jump
back to the browser
where we had the error before.
And let's put in
a query parameter
called key equals API key.
And there we go.
Now we're getting back
data instead of the error.
Our API is secured.
We have a way to get
credentials and a way
to get access to our API.
So now let's jump
back into slides.
And let's recap what we did
and what we saw in this demo.
All right, so great, we've
set up our API gateway.
We have configured it to point
to our Cloud Run services.
And now we've added
security on top of it.
So we're done, right?
Well, in a sense, yes-- but
if this were a real production
API, as you know,
we're going to have
to actually operate,
and maintain,
and manage this thing.
And a big part of that is
going to be monitoring our API
to make sure that it's
working the way we expect.
So why don't we jump
into our next demo
now and take a look at how
we can use cloud logging
and cloud monitoring
to set up an alert,
so that if something is
going wrong with our API,
we'll get alerted about it.
For our last demo, we're
going to take a look
at how we might monitor APIs.
So to do that, we're
going to come down here
to the operation section of
the Cloud Console menu, pick
Monitoring, and then Alerting
underneath the Monitoring menu.
To start off, we're going
to create a new policy.
And let's talk a little bit
about what types of things
we might want to monitor.
We might want to look at
things like error rates
that are creeping up too high.
We might want to look at
the amount of traffic that's
coming through our API.
Or in this case, what
we're going to show
is how we can monitor the
backend latency and get
alerted if all of a sudden
our backend for our API
is taking longer to respond
than a specific threshold.
Let's start by giving our
alerting policy a name.
We're going to call
it slow backend.
And then we're going
to add a condition.
The first thing we need to do
is define the right resource
that we want to monitor.
Now, for API gateway, all
of the resources and metrics
that we're going
to report are going
to be underneath the
produced API resource.
So that's what we're
going to select here
for our first condition.
Once we've selected
that resource,
we can pick from a
number of metrics.
In this case, we're going to
pick request backend latency.
From here, we need to
select the aggregator.
We could look at things here
like the 50th percentile,
95th percentile.
In this case, I'm going to pick
the 99th percentile, because I
want to understand what the
worst latency the consumers
are experiencing.
And then the last
thing that we're
going to need to do
under Configuration
is to set a threshold.
I'm going to set that
pretty low, just to 10
milliseconds, just to make
sure it's going to be easy
for us to trigger
this alert and we
can verify that it's working.
And then the very
last thing we'll do
is we'll just click on Add.
And then that will bring
us back to our main
create alerting
policy form here.
And the next thing we're
going to need to do
is to set up a
notification channel.
We have different types
that we can choose from.
I'm just going to do a
very simple notification
channel here of email.
And I'm going to enter my
own email address in here.
We'll click on Add.
And then that's going to be it.
We can add documentation
if we want.
But I'm just going
to click on Save.
And now at this point,
our alert is created.
And our next step is going
to be to start generating
some traffic to see if
we can trigger this alert
and make sure that we're getting
an email if our latencies start
to creep up.
So all we have to do to
generate load-- let's
just come back over to the
browser we were using before.
And we're just going to start
hitting our backend with just
a whole bunch of API calls.
We'll just keep smashing
the Refresh button
and sending those API calls.
And hopefully that will be
enough to trigger an alert here
before too long.
If we go back to the
monitoring UI now and refresh,
we should see a new
alert that's popped up.
And we do.
If we click on this, we'll
be able to get some details
about the alert,
exactly what happened,
what was the latency
that we were seeing,
verify that it did
exceed the threshold.
And then if I go
to my inbox, I'll
also see that I did get
notified about this alert being
triggered.
And now if I were the person
responsible for monitoring
this API and operating this
API, I could go dig into this
and figure out what's going on.
And we can take
corrective action
to make sure that we correct
any problems that are occurring.
Hopefully this gives
you a good idea
for how you can set up
monitoring and alerting
for APIs that are managed
by the API gateway.
And with that, let's jump
back into slides and recap
what we saw here in this demo.
All right, so now we've
seen how to build APIs.
We've seen how to
secure those APIs.
And now we've seen how
to monitor those APIs
and make sure that we're going
to get an alert if anything's
not working correctly.
So we hope that through this
demo and the presentation,
you've gotten a taste for what
you can do with our new API
gateway product, which,
again, we just recently
announced in beta.
I wanted to spend a
little bit of time talking
to you about the things
that we have on our roadmap
and where we see this
product evolving over
the coming months.
So the first thing
to talk about is
API gateway and how we see
this serving GCP customers.
If you're someone who
is building web apps,
you're building mobile apps
or multi-experience apps that
are using APIs on
GCP, we really want
to make that process
a lot easier for you,
not only just routing to
things like serverless,
but also helping
you compose APIs.
So if you have data
that's in BigQuery,
you have data that is
running on serverless
or non-serverless
compute, maybe even
data that's in your
data center that you
want to connect to
via VPC, we want
to make that process
extremely easy for you.
If you're building out apps
that need authentication
and you want to use things
like Google Cloud's Identity
Platform, we're working
closely with those teams
to bring you a
solution that's going
to make it much, much easier to
build those applications on top
of Google Cloud.
Now, specifically
in our short term,
we have a few enhancements that
I'd like to make you aware of.
We've had an overwhelming
amount of demand for open API V3
support.
And we've heard
you loud and clear.
Our team is working
hard to implement open
API V3 for API gateway.
We're expecting to have
something out for you
in the very, very
first part of 2021.
We're also working to integrate
with the Google Cloud Load
Balancer.
And that's going to
do a couple of things.
That's going to
give you the ability
to configure integration with
products such as Cloud Armor.
So if you need DDoS protection,
you need [INAUDIBLE]
top 10 protection, IP
filtering, and so forth, it's
going to be a great
solution for you,
as well as integration with
our cloud CDN for caching
those responses.
For those of you that are more
interested in full lifecycle
API management,
we're working really
closely with the
Apigee team as well
to bring you integration with
Apigee features such as API
products and Apigee's
developer portals.
So on behalf of the entire
team here at GCP, especially
the serverless team, the Apigee
team, and the API gateway team,
we are so thankful for
you taking the time
to watch our session here today.
And we really look forward
to getting your feedback
on the product.
Thank you so much.